-Welcome to "The Tonight Show"
at SummerStage in Central Park!
[ Cheers and applause ]
We have got a huge show
for you tonight.
From the movie "A Simple Favor,"
Blake Lively is here
this evening.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Country-music superstar
Carrie Underwood is here!
[ Cheers and applause ]
And New York City is here
tonight, ladies and gentlemen!
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's fantastic.
We've got some special guests.
The one and only
New York Philharmonic
is here with The Roots,
ladies and gentlemen.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And we have 1,500 people
in our audience tonight.
Look at you guys.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah.
Of course, tickets
to tonight's show were free.
So if you paid for those
on the street outside,
I'm sorry and welcome
to New York City.
Uh, that's...
Tonight we're making history
as the first late-night show
ever in Central Park.
[ Cheers and applause ]
But, uh...
But, you guys,
I was born in New York.
I was raised in New York.
I live in New York now.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I am such a New Yorker,
I can honestly say
I've only been to Central Park,
like, once before.
I've driven through it
in a cab, but, yeah.
For those of you who aren't
familiar with the park,
we thought it might be helpful
to show you
some key sights here.
Let's take a look at this map.
First up,
here's the SummerStage.
That's where we are right now.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Next up, here's
a beautiful walking path
through the woods
called The Ramble.
Fun fact -- that's where
they find all the bodies
on "Law & Order."
Next up, here's a statue
of Alexander Hamilton.
That's the only place in New
York City you can see Hamilton
without spending
1,000 bucks on StubHub.
Next up, here's
Strawberry Fields.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's where every bad
guitar player in New York goes
to ruin Beatles songs.
Of course, here's the Boathouse.
Beautiful.
That's where you see
two people on a bad date
because they can't leave because
they're stuck on a boat.
And finally
here's the Great Lawn...
or, as New York City dogs
call it, the master bathroom.
What an amazing place.
[ Cheers and applause ]